piece of information which might be in
that Alan gray you'll have noticed the
name of the composer of the film scores
Alan gray and that's quite surprising
because one might have expected that one
of the leading film composers British
film composers such as Ralph Vaughan
Williams or not max yeah one of those
one of those leading names of british
music associated with you know landscape
imagery already with an established
reputation might have been asked but in
fact alan gray is the is that you know
the professional name of user from me
Grodd who was a Polish composer trained
under Arnold Schoenberg who wrote this
score and he was he knew Emmerich
Pressburger from who fathered german
film consortium in the 1930s leading
musical figure in the bimah Republic so
it's actually not the it's not the kind
of indigenous musical product that you
might expect but I think he did an
absolutely brilliant job where that did
seem to come hope that there's this
extraordinary moment with the bar where
you have to deal with the the fact that
the cathedral is filled not with English
music we have the English choral music
William Byrd choral music be practiced
by the choir who we never see and that's
the authentic medieval English product
that's the pure product but then bar
comes in on the organ and really
complicates this very straightforward
identification of English music as kind
of authentic and which we've been living
with up to that point we have the
pilgrims initially introduced with with
a medieval chant and at and so on but
then with bark the music both signifies
transcendental your Transfiguration the
shafts of light through the gothic
window the organ fulfilment and then it
also signifies German pneus and the same
music as we move outside when we hear
Lee upholster coughs Keys orchestration
of that bark piece it moves seamlessly
from the organ into the orchestra we're
then dealing with bark as German and we
actually we're surveying the bombed
streets of Canterbury with the same
music that uh Carter
d moved into the orchestra and suddenly
it signifies luftwaffe so I think that's
one of the most brilliant moments of
sort of our old transport confusion
really as a transition that you find in
the film and it's a quite a brilliant
move then to transit back into those
bells which are you know authentic
forged by the kind of same guy that we
saw in the in the blacksmith's shop you
know whacking away at his piece of at
his piece of iron as his predecessors
had done so I did think that that that
sounds paper and then of course there's
a sort of Glenn Miller moment in there
as well so the use of sound to you know
construct a cultural idiom is the thing
that I really noticed this time I'm sure
everyone else has got different themes
that they'd like to bring um sure um I
guess this is interesting what you say
about the cathedral and I guess it
reminds me of Miss Miniver a Hollywood
film that was however starring Greg
arson and also very popular in Britain
which was about the Blitz and the the
kind of coming of war and what it meant
and a lot of that there's a there's a
kind of weepy Christmas seen in a ruined
Church whose roof has come off and
everybody is kind of congregating
they're celebrating this film is also
made at the same time that in Germany
whose war was going less and less well
at this point there are films also set
in ruined buildings and ruined
cathedrals which are kind of deeply
melancholic films about the end of the
world coming and how one sort of
preserves and this film is very dilek in
comparison to those things I also wanted
to just add that actually the number of
German and German Jewish émigrés is
involved in this film seems to be quite
extensive Alfred Junge did the
photography or the or maybe the measles
send and he's a very well-known designer
who is one of those links that Christy
mentioned with German Expressionism in
the vaio republic i also just wanted to
say something about this in conjunction
to powell and pressburger films in
general some of you may know I know
where I'm going a slightly earlier
more romantic even Blythe her film about
the war which is set in the highlands
and also the voice of the old prophecy
which speaks and there's also a sense of
the palimpsest adults uses the Falcon it
also uses a sense of a kind of buried
feudal past that's kind of under
everything but they go on after the war
to make peeping tom and I would just
like to point out that that is in this
movie too and there is something I've
always been riveted but sort of vaguely
horrified by this film which i think is
a very interesting and weird amalgam of
you know the wholesome patriotic here's
Britain as a kind of cultural palimpsest
and like what is wrong with this
sexually frustrated man who is wreaking
this petty I mean they take a lot of
pains to tell us this is trivial but
it's not trivial he's kind of defacing
women to try to drive them out to create
a Preserve where he can give men a
patriotic education and as the as our
land girl says briskly well did you ever
imagine that inviting the women to come
and participate in the kind of patriotic
education held in the museum oh no no he
hadn't he hadn't really thought of that
and of course he's hoping that she will
end up being the love interest but you
know miraculously and kind of counter
factually her dead fiance comes back to
life and is there at the end of the film
after the film's what seems to me the
film's most poignant scene where she's
opening the caravan which is this
carefully sealed off place of past it'll
at its moth-eaten and falling apart and
she realizes she's really really lost
him he's died years ago now it's never
coming back and of course a few minutes
later he is back which means that
there's this leftover person this
pervert who is going to have to go and
you know he could have been redeemed by
the antiquarian girl you know wearing
coveralls that could have that could
have sort of started another chapter
going but
that's kind of gone so anyway and I
guess just one last word since you had
mentioned these other studios including
the the private life of henry the eighth
the alexander korda which is of course
of Viennese kind of style brought into
British cinema in a way even at the
beginning of the film the Evoque ation
of the Canterbury pilgrims this is done
in a kind of style of ribble jollity
which is really associated with that
studio so you have this kind of Viennese
studio that comes and makes these films
about English history they also make the
Alexander Korda also makes the famous
Rembrandt biography which is a very
beautiful humanist film but also you
know lust for life and somehow that's
here as the epitome of Englishness and
it's it's weird that you have that as an
undertone I do think you're right it's
there in the music at the same time that
with the the man from Oregon and the
girlfriend who's been posted to
Australia you have a kind of
Cosmopolitan sphere of the
english-speaking world kind of radiating
out from Britain over the long term and
now weirdly kind of centering back on
canterbury now used as a troop send-off
place which I can't imagine is actually
I can't imagine there was actually an
official troops and off from inside the
cathedral maybe maybe there was but uh
huh and of course no separation of
church and state right are you all right
yes okay good at least yes the the III
to stumble of the airport the squire
and it's it is a now it appears to us as
rather repulsive is misogyny and let me
lay that to one side for a second what's
also can you take a little closer to the
mic them sorry x yeah what's also
difficult is his Heidi garyun view of
the world that this this is profoundly
about roots of place and you know if you
have a caravan well then you're not a
civilized person is obviously right so
that there are grounds for being
ideologically suspicious of this
gentleman on the other hand I was very
interesting what you said about the
cosmopolitan in this sense of kind of
because of course the I don't you may
have said I came back I came in too late
I may have missed something you said in
the introduction but the the sergeant
who was an actor who who was actually
touring in a play of thought in thornton
wilder's our town an official american
arts but he gave his salary for this
film to the NAACP I i find it one of the
most extraordinary statements of how can
we say democratic socialism patriotic
national patriotic socialism it's I know
those are deputy those words together
there's a danger yeah inherent even when
I put those words together very very
difficult and it's also so
overwhelmingly emotional I try and stay
away from from this as I stay away from
unpretending films because they are so
powerful emotionally if you're English
they're very dangerous films indeed
could I just say something about that
squaring of German music and
yeah it comes up again in Humphrey
Jennings listen to Britain sorry I'd
you've been talking about that I I am
when um we heared aim higher at Myra
Hess playing in an empty national
gallery and a voiceover we are told that
this this is a German composer and this
is something we may have to think about
after the war and so it's putting all
these contrary I think what's so
extraordinary liz is putting repulsive
ideologies of patriarchy of place and
nation and racial identity together with
the most transcendent themes of
liberation as well and I I find an
extremely difficult film to do to deal
with the other thing is the ID Giri amid
the deracinated life that we hear about
Dennis price and for actor who plays in
a places in a cinema but it's all right
these people have been blessed and saved
by this experience so so there is this
this redemptive strong redemptive
element yeah yeah I hope this Mike's
gonna work now yeah before we open it
out I'd like to just respond to some of
those comments and particularly and what
you say Katie about the sexual violence
pro I mean that we've all kind of noted
and this wasn't lost on critics at the
time and it's actually really
interesting to connect this to other
extremely violent films at the time when
you look at this film that the war is in
some ways so completely absent from it
the only seen we have of combat is this
kind of ersatz children's warfare which
actually was cut from the american
version interestingly so this seems to
be kind of the only place that we see
any conflict and one would be tempted to
think of this as censorship in some way
and yet if we think about this in
relation
to a film like went the day well which I
don't know how many have you seen this
but you know you have the vicar's wife
gunning down german paratroopers with a
machine gun you have a housewife
butchering German invaders with a meat
cleaver it's actually really graphic
film like the Gainsborough melodramas as
well we have women crossdressing and
committing armed robbery so it wasn't
really this question of censorship but
audiences really found the women having
sticky stuff squirted into the hair in
the night extremely distasteful and when
peeping tom came out in nineteen sixty
people said aha this was a red flag we
should have known Powell was a pervert
from day one and it's actually really
hard not to see Culpepper as an analog
for Powell particularly with him
standing in that sort of you know as I
said this or reflective cinematic moment
of him presenting the slide lecture and
expounding on the role of explicitly
movies in cultural life so it is
interesting that critics at the time did
find extremely distasteful and this
didn't do well at all at the box office
which is in part why it was recut for
American audiences and maybe if we have
time we'll watch the opening of the
American film because it's so
interesting just how different the tone
is but maybe we could I can sort of run
out with the mic and we could open it
out if people have questions or comments
we have another mic maybe
does anyone have a question I'm
wondering about Isis on the new are
qualities because certain things come to
mind when the term is used and certainly
the shadows and the lighting and all of
these things made me think of Fritz Lang
specifically like Ministry of fear which
is definitely more violence and set in
London but what about that because I was
I guess I was like I was anticipating
more violence yeah and sort of cloak and
dagger espionage something like that so
yeah if I could respond and
interestingly just an anecdotal thing
that Fritz Lang later recalled watching
Ministry of fear and television and
falling asleep and saying it was one of
those films he ever made but the point
is well taken and that's something I
sort of wanted to touch on in the
introduction that I think it's really
easy just to say that no I'll happens
because you have German Expressionists
making movies and the cancer retail
could almost be used as an example of
that because we do have as Katie
mentioned so many Emma Gray's European
émigré Hungarian German working on the
film and I think this really complicates
that idea of noir as just a product of
kind of a second-generation expression a
cinema and thinking about if in the
American context it's very much a
paranoia over the state of the industry
what does it mean full Britain to have
this also you know similar into a star
and there were you know film noir proper
that the British art center actuated a
series of British film noir and this
doesn't sit that easily with that
description so i think it is really
interesting you know in a way that
Antonio lamp has done to think about
noir is kind of a condition of the
everyday in Britain that everyday life
suddenly becomes like living in a film
noir and so it's all
most even though we over privileged
realist cinema in Britain to think about
how this is realest rather than an
expressionist a reflection of the actual
scenario of blackout but maybe the rest
of you have responses to that well I do
think there's a way of thinking about I
mean why is Expressionism what it is in
the first place well you know it's a
it's a pre-war German movement which is
about existential angst and panic even
before the war then it's magnified by
the war and then it's enormously
successful commercially it becomes kind
of the visibly German exports style and
so that's one of the reasons it sort of
exported but a lot of the noir films are
actually about the effects of the war on
the German economy the inflation and so
on so basically it becomes a style which
is often used either to describe like
sheer horror gothic horror or you know
fantasy films monster films of various
kinds or it's being used to describe the
kind of shadow nature of daily life in
the early 20th century and as such it's
a helpful shorthand to think either
about you know the creeping menace of
German fascism and how it's contaminated
British life and or spread its way
across Europe turning everything into a
miserable defeated Germany equivalent or
it's seen more universally and I think
that in listen to Britain the effect of
to my mind the effect of having de Meyer
has playing the Britons playing the
German composers it's not really
anticipating a moment where the Germans
will come they'll wipe everything out
they'll wipe our culture out and they'll
be imposing their culture instead
because she's playing I think Beethoven
and so there's this Schumann and
Beethoven so there's a sense these this
is a piece of universal cultural
heritage and there's a good Germany and
there's an evil Germany and we have to
kind of keep them separate it out and of
course the émigré is tried hard and two
degree fruitlessly to keep making that
distinction we are the other Germany
we're not that Germany so in a way you
could see the use of this German style
as a kind of shorthand for
German imposed existential despair in a
way you could think of it as a style
which helps people in other other but
related situations think about
underlying deep moral anxieties
theological anxieties existential
anxieties you know both before during
and after the war David did you well I
think if it is neo-noir oh no I'm sorry
I'm sorry we start again if it is
partakes of moi you know it also a chunk
of this is english antiquarian yeah very
big chunk of he clearly either is a
champion of the council for the
preservation of rural England he's also
there's hints of he's an AB Cup erson he
educates the troops yeah that's that but
what is educating them with is not your
Britain fight for it now and you get a
new health center or a hospital or all
the things we saw you'll get some you
know further excavations on the hill
back there which are bound to but that
that seems very important the the idea
of the opening up of of the of an
English past and that's why I selected
that alain soral image of the the cavern
in the in the clouds and what seemed
below is actually a piece of modern
engineering it's an airfield but on the
other hand given its alain soral it just
as well might be part of an old Roman
town that's been reconstructed
underneath so that idea relay errs of
history is is under finding a lyrical
style that will do that for you and a
narrative that will do that for you
that's what one of the things that's
interesting in the film yeah and it's
interesting to think about this in terms
of propaganda cinema this was the fourth
or fifth film about the wall that Powell
and Pressburger made
and if we think about in relationship to
things like the 49th parallel which won
an Oscar which was so explicitly
propagandistic to try and get America
involved in the war for those of you who
haven't seen it a German soldiers kind
of go on a killing spree through Canada
and then find refuge in neutral America
so yeah it's very explicitly about
trying to get America into the war but
you're Pressburger said and I had this
quote he says Goebbels considered
himself an expert on propaganda but I
thought I'd show him a thing or two and
it's actually really hard to think about
this in terms of propaganda it's so so
complicated compared to some of those
more explicit films that are being made
at this time so other questions comments
or tims well just can just add one
little thing but I don't want to lose
these these comments it's just that the
the sort of extraordinary akhir oscuro
of dark and light because they're it
there are the noir moments which are
probably what one-third of the film
which is literally when it's dog or when
you're inside and then the rest of the
film is this euphoric slightly
overexposed images of the English
countryside in the most you know there's
this may time the loss and the clouds
and with the ruins nestling within lads
and that aesthetic is the aesthetic of
the English picturesque watercolor and
of course really so 1790 and of Chris
seemed against the backdrop of this
conference there were there were
hundreds of moments which triggered the
images there was the skull under the
field there was there was the Samuel
Palmer ask night scene there was the the
trailing clouds that you talked about
those those kind of marks in the air etc
etc so really you know there's a panoply
of everything the visual art is doing is
happening here as well there's an
interesting slip of the images the
French Eustace promotion amor its Tory's
used to say where we the camera comes up
and we see hundreds of barrage balloons
yeah and it's repeated and there are
contrails swerving around because of
course what what the war has been sealed
off although the war has entered for the
English living
the southeast quadrant Britain the
almost the most deadly phase more people
will die in the missile attacks of which
begin in June July 1944 only end in
March April 45 and their those balloons
are there to try and stop the v1
missiles they're there against the v2
which comes on stream in the autumn
there is no defense we've entered
although the nuclear weapons are not
being used but we've entered the the
nuclear age of bombardment and it's it
is it's it's a terror and I I think of
the fragility of that life and the
balloons tried trying to ward off this
this appalling thrill and because of
course a town like Antwerp falls under
missile attack as well and is very badly
damaged I think we have a question or a
comment yeah I was really struck by you
know they're all redeemed in the end the
three main characters you know with with
culpeper really performing the role of
the director he's there you know
presiding when she finds the the caravan
and then finds that her lover's alive
and all that is that's the miracle and
she is restored legitimacy by the by the
future father-in-law but before that the
caravan really is the scene of
premarital sex that's yeah that's stated
throughout and the the British sergeant
who talks about playing cards with the
boys and doesn't have a female partner
and is an artist and so on you know has
all the connotations of a gay man who is
given you know equal sympathy and equal
stature and of course she allison is you
know this radiant figure who
is a renegade from conventional morality
and I think despite the you know the
metaphysical ending the what's proceeded
in fact is very sympathetic toward
people's individual lives especially as
they may have been disrupted in wartime
but I was really amazed by that because
that's the kind of thing you didn't
usually get away with in a mainstream
feeling I have to say though I had a
very weird experience about 15 years ago
I was on an alumni cruise of the Danube
with Yale and Chicago alums and one of
the more outspoken people everybody
talked about the war all the way down
the danube and one of the more outspoken
women said to me just blowing my mind
you realize that everybody here who's
talking about the war they all had
premarital sex of course they did their
their boyfriends were about to go off
and get killed of course they had
premarital sex forget what your mother
intimated to you about what happened
it's all completely misleading and that
was a very demystifying moment and I do
think the film sets it up so that we
understand it in something like that
context they were engaged for three
years if only they could have been
married then they would have been able
to have a normal conjugal life which was
blessed they weren't able to get married
so hence you know she accompanied him to
his work and then saw him off at the
front he died luckily she had had that
time with him so there's a lot of
explanatory framework about this but I
and I do think the interesting thing is
that Culpepper is also sympathetic to
this so despite the fact he is phobic
about women and phobic about their you
know their their ability to drain men of
their vital education seeking powers etc
etc you know even he concedes well this
made sense given this life-and-death
situation that people were it and there
is after all that that weird scene in
the train where they're saying you know
and they talk about well shouldn't girls
get to have fun and I do think one of
the weird things about this film is it's
almost like a feminist detective film
like a kind of feminist detective film
of all know that you know there were
those films of the 70s where the women
go around interviewing other women
trying to figure out what do women want
and in a way
you know there's a kind of relay of
women who are finding one another in
comparing notes and people at women in
all walks of life who are somehow
banding together to you know pin down
who this perpetrator is and that's that
and that Allison's attitude is I'm not
going to let it scare me i'm annoyed and
i'm angry and so it's a kind of militant
i refuse to let this scare me out of
town or anything like that i'm not going
to be budged by this you think I haven't
seen worse than this this is the kind of
petty tyranny and you know we're dealing
with yeah yeah Mike sorry and then also
from lover came up the dead again so
what does that mean that her lover came
up from the dead and the sergeant was a
carpenter so I kept on seeing the
carpenter
well in a way this is a film that
suffused with religious imagery i mean
the canterbury and the quest for
Canterbury's so i think there's
absolutely something to that in it and
it doesn't exactly all co here but
there's a way in which we're supposed to
be opening ourselves to a kind of
mystical frame of mind where things that
would otherwise be seen as coincidences
are far-fetched do take on this aura of
the miraculous and I think you're right
there's all this preparation of all
kinds of different ways for that
eventual kind of shift of register in
the film yeah I think often in Powell
and Pressburger films what could be read
as religiosity is more spiritualism as a
counter against materialism if that
makes sense particularly things like I
know where I'm going that it's a
narrative about a girl who wants to
marry incorporated chemical industries
and realizes that actually what she
wants is to live the simple life in the
Scottish islands inhale that even has a
comparable scene there's the moment when
the everybody's in the train car and
they're going towards Canterbury and
they say oh well he wouldn't have a halo
and he turns and he does have a healer
there's a similar moment and I know
where I'm going which is very kind of
surreal a sequence where they're in the
train station and this representative of
consolidated chemicals kind of turns in
his hat his top hat you know eject smoke
as if he's a devil and there's a kind of
hellish whiff of sulfur emanating from
him in a film that's otherwise realists
so there's a similar kind of touch i
think and you know you get the train and
the people and the pilgrimage together
and you can kind of conjure up a bits
and pieces of this much older cultural
framework
yeah um I wrecked you have a question
yes I betta find myself thinking David
David already mentioned a place and
Heidegger and that's been a problematic
notion of place that seems to be part of
the film I think that's very much true
but I also wonder if there's a way in
which this film is also in part
problematizing a sense of place for
instance I wonder about the role of the
American seems to be primarily to be
lost right there's also the scene with
the village idiot which is worse one of
the darkest shots in the film and one of
the first words that pops out of their
mouth is topography and they're looking
around and wondering where to go and
even as the film approaches its end
there seemed to be and I think this is
true at the same to be an acceleration
of different angles different you know
that the crane shots going piercing the
cathedral an inversion of the the
direction of the camera and of course
Canterbury itself is not the end of the
journey here right the people are going
off in different directions so it just
seems to me that that that I wonder if
there's an importance to this kind of
quality of a losing place in the film
and losing a sense of orientation and
knowledge well in a way that that album
that David showed of the I'm sure you
pick this partly thinking that the film
was coming right I have to confess yes
right and I I kind of grind right
including this the skewed cottage and
the the narrow streets and so in a way
it's you know uncle Josh goes to the
picture show it's the skewed rube vision
of things which which we start with only
to move into this other ground Mickey
Powell was regarded his main influence
wasn't German cinema it was Rudyard
Kipling
yes and and Kipling Kipling and again
Kipling who went violently out of
fashion because of his perceived
imperialism but nevertheless somebody
Kipling who who wants to see spiritual
currents running through things that the
cut through history and cuts through and
this is crucial geographic global sites
so that whether it's India or Africa or
whatever so Kipling isn't an imperial
figure but but also in a positive side
of seeing the globe as a set of
interconnections there's also pack of
yeah pooks Hill which is a kind of palam
sestak text at the turn of the century
which is quite now kind of forgotten but
quite influential which again has the
sense of all these residues I just
wanted to also raise the issue of these
children I guess I'm haunted by this
partly because it's my perception that
children children's writing about both
Wars I wrote an article at one point
about the the stark contrast between
children's writing about war in the
British context and in the German
context and the German contacts already
narrowed as a world war one or semi
apocalyptic and there's always a sense
of how incredibly dark it is and people
go back to the thirty years war into
criminals housing into you know
apocalyptic texts to kind of find a way
to describe what's happening and British
narratives especially of world war one
but even if World War two are very
influenced by baden-powell you know the
the hero of math a king and the boy
scouts and the Boer War energies in the
sense that children are going to be
mobilized as a kind of militia and that
it's a game and that so the fact that
this ends with the football game with or
a soccer game with the children playing
and with the sense children are fanning
out kind of reenacting or but that's
actually cute it's not violent or
disturbing or scary or a sign of how
traumatized they are it's a kind of
miniaturization of war and analyzation
of war i to me that's a striking aspect
of the film which isn't merited by the
overall situation where
as the Life magazine cover suggested you
know there were many many orphaned
children traumatized children Anna Freud
had set up these special clinics trying
to deal with children who had been
buried under buildings on how to kind of
bring them back to health and people who
had lost family members its or even just
thinking about you know what would you
do if your family member after an air
raid was put on to a hospital train and
vanished how would you figure out where
they were that would be so existentially
terrifying so if we think about what the
civilian situation was like on the
ground which was deeply chaotic and
confusing this does not get it that at
all it's on some other plane altogether
ask a question to follow up on that
especially that scene children playing
war and just going to ask maybe in terms
of the British context whether that
particular image children playing war
becomes a trope and as I if I understood
it right it was cut for the American
context which I find very interesting
because in them in the American context
you do find this kind of trope of
children fleeing war as this kind of
Cocteau like a fun terrible you see it
in Philip Guston you see an intuitive so
I find it really interesting that it
gets cut and so I was wondering if you
can speak to the difference of
perception that would happen in relation
to that scene in British and American
context I'm the the key film to think
about here immediately post war is a
kneeling film called hue and cry where
gangs of and they appear to be often a
day of inner-city London kids play in
the Blitz and play at various games then
rather like a meal are borrowing from a
meal and the detectives they then take
part in rounding up criminals see if
certain people but but we see them very
poignant shots of them running around in
the ruins as if we're in Naples you know
and there's street children and you were
absolutely right thinking of pocket
pooks Hill
i know i've been i've brought dragged in
very personal anecdotes but well I was
working on Paradise Lost and make if I
was still alive and I brought my son to
to see him and we were talking and he
said he asked me if i did i read Parker
pooks hill to Leo my son and I said yeah
and he did something it feels a
startling of some of the images in the
film he said then I bless you both which
feels as if it's out of that narrative
and it took us a back but we were also
you know I'm sure though somewhere those
a blind date those vault of lights but
he was an extraordinary person and
that's why I i feel i cannot wholly join
in a condemnation of elements here we
are dealing with a set of contradictions
and yeah yeah and maybe just speaking
about the the american version i
understand that it was largely cut to
squeeze it down to fit better into a
double feature and that that was one
scene that didn't contribute too much to
the plot you could cut it it wouldn't
affect it too much which actually see I
mean to me that seems like such an
important allegorical scene it's
interesting that that's that's what they
chose to trim out I don't know if if
people want to see that we have sort of
a short clip from the opening of the
american version which I just think it's
so interesting if we could get it's on
this disc american version exits if i
cancel I think it's really interesting
that's still in the American version you
get the kubrick match cut yeah um that I
I just have to believe that he saw that
and that's where oh my mom and that one
yeah 49 but also so much for English
history yeah see I was really I was
really keen for everyone to see that
because that bully my mind yeah also the
fact so a whole plot strand has no
suspense left in it whatsoever that's
also the effective yeah the miracle is
revealed in the
does anyone have any thoughts about that
you might recognize kim hunter as the
American love interest in a matter of
life a matter of life or death which is
another interesting film to think about
in relationship to you know in the same
boat as a theme and the extensive trial
at the end about sort of the morality of
an anglo-american relationship but um
any other questions or comments I did
just wonder how the politics of the film
would play in America because I mean
it's it's and you know David I'd like to
hear your you're much more more well
better informed thoughts on this but it
has a kind of fascinating sort of 19th
century Tory kind of political world
view I mean because you know you you
invoke the health service there's so
many of these war films have a kind of
sense of everyone coming together to
form a new polity in the face of
adversity and there's absolutely not a
hint of that here the idea that the
society is being transformed you know
it's absolutely more that the kind of
it's like some vid Victorian FD Maurice
for example that the Christian socialist
who said that if only you realize that
everyone has their place in earth and
that God is revealed to us through the
cat to the church everything will be
fine it's just it's just extraordinarily
resistant to the kind of collectivist
politics of the exact moment that we're
talking a beverage report I mean this is
exact same day well not only that but it
seems to sort of reinforce it seems to
sanction and reinforce the misogynist
strains of the film I mean you know the
couples who are married or fighting oh
yes I promise you because we weren't
married yet now we are married I mean
this is fairly hideous actually yeah
yeah there's a moment which you hardly
hear you have to be primed to hear but
when the sergeant goes into the
wheelwrights work
I you may have picked this people may
pick this up and in the argument about
how long you do you wait before you cut
and then the venerable the kind of
spirit of the English landscape you says
bloody capitalists yes yes yes and as
because and this does not make it a
socialist radical film one iota it is
what it is is an agrarian mistrust of of
money coming from the universe it's a
kind of it's a very interesting politic
but there's a hint of Morris's news from
nowhere at that moment the idea that you
know if you if you journey far enough up
the Thames Valley you can get back into
a sort of world in which the workmen and
his products are not alienated and that
yeah that that's that moment with with
the wheelwrights hmm and the perfect we
all being made and everyone knowing the
skills that is a kind of mercian moment
and kipling and kipling right and keep
all who worked very closely connected
that's returns that's right and it's
interesting that the the class politics
I think play out is town and country
here in a way if you think about another
war film millions like us about women
coming from all kinds of different
social backgrounds you have the Welsh
Miner's Daughter sort of London social I
the Lancashire glass and they all sort
of come together and become friends at
the end and this there's not really any
discussion of class here in a you know
and I think that's really what those
with angry young men films are getting
at the end that actually class really
did matter in the war particularly room
at the top you have Joe sort of distrust
of them someone who he fought with in
the war but because he was an
oxford-educated sort of much higher
ranking person you know these these
kinds of antagonisms were there and I
just completely effaced um no no I I
just had a thought on a completely
different track and it's because I've
been talking to some people through the
day about
American isolationism and what had to be
overcome and you mentioned the earlier
film that they had done which was
designed to to you know overcome that in
the United States so I was struck in a
film made in 1944 when you think this
would be a dead issue that they lash out
at the isolationists and how the
sergeant say that though well you know
they've been putting the wrong you know
not they're no longer having any voice
but if that were true you wouldn't have
to put that line in the movie and so I
was interested in the thoughts of all of
you or you know much closer to this
material about the lingering you know
specter of of American isolationism and
german-american an irish-american lack
of sympathy for the support for Britain
picture post put a picture of Joseph
Kennedy on the front and the caption was
a true friend to Britain and of course
people what people did not know who was
the briefings he's giving to roosevelt
and and the very important role he's
playing in the isolationist camp a
defeatist camp so maybe maybe the
English were more anxious about well
maybe these guys are going to peel away
leave us on our own in a moment and I
don't know so the Life magazine cover of
the girl in the hospital bed which was
have 42 know that that's beginning of 41
or even late for tea yeah so that would
be in the first wave of you know
cementing Americans yet board for
Britain is using you know a time-honored
way of propagandizing for that there's
actually something of a range of movies
right at the end of the war and the very
beginning of the post-war period about
the ongoing tensions in
an anglo-american relations kind of on
the ground people fighting over girls
the the you know they're dating our
women and in a way you could say maybe
the question of isolationism it's being
recast as you know it's sort of dueling
provincial isms but British
provincialism has a lot more immediate
depth than American provincialism
although even American provincialism
turns out to have its noble moments and
you know that has a pioneering spirit it
also understands the spirituality of
trees you know it's got its own
pantheistic elements etc etc but seems
to me the the wheelwright scene is
absolutely about securing that though it
is an odd failure of continuity there
that the the dinner with the wheelwright
never occurs and it's also interesting
thinking about that little conversation
about the lease lend that because that's
nestled in the children's battle scene i
wonder if that was also cut for the
american release and I don't know that
would be interesting well I like you to
join me in thanking my fellow panelists
this has been a really really
interesting discussion so thank you so
much well I think before we all depart
it will be a great moment text you to
thank all the speakers in this
remarkably coherent and also enjoyable
and collegial conference and to thank
Eric and Tatiana for the idea and Sophie
for joining the team and delivering the
idea so beautifully to us since with
such such a lack of a single glitch
through the whole the whole series of
events so well it's too late now
template so no but thank you all and
thanks to our two great keynotes because
as well Cecile and David really really
appreciate all of you coming thank
you